buenas tardes gracias base escarban por
estar aquí
la invitación gracias al público que se
ha portado muy bien y que estamos
presentando un nuevo formato
bueno pues viendo viendo todo tu
background
nos impactó muchísimo y nos alegra
siendo ciudadanos de monterrey que desde
aquí se impulse la industria de los
contenidos audiovisuales y quería
comenzar que entiendes por los efectos
efectos visuales que son que si son que
no son
bueno primero que nada los efectos
visuales es todo lo que es imposible de
crear y reproducir en la vida real
los monstruos explosiones que son
demasiado peligrosas de realizar el set
de simulaciones de fluidos todo lo que
es muy costoso o es imposible de
reproducir en set se puede realizar por
medio de gráficas computacionales y esa
es nuestra especialidad recrear lo que
lo que no es posible aquí y cuéntanos un
poco cómo llegaste y que te empezó a
mover cuando estaba el chiquillo de
repente sabes que me gusta muchísimo
este este contenido quiero ver a ese
niño muy inquieto de muchas películas
son más bien un tipo reservado y que de
repente va no sé cómo llegué como
descubriste es en este mundo cuando yo
creo que yo siempre fui en lo cual la
familia empezando porque bueno de
chiquito yo siempre me gusta mucho lo
explico de ciencia ficción y la historia
de los efectos visuales en sí van de la
mano con la ciencia ficción
entonces yo viendo de documentales de
cómo se hacían las películas
sorprendidos siempre de cómo pueden como
pueden alcanzar acb sus en realidad son
cosas esos escenarios esos personajes
que en realidad no pueden existir en la
vida real
eso me llevó a tener la espinita de
investigar por mi propia cuenta yo soy
el género de sonora y investigue lo más
parecido a lo que yo quería era la
carrera de animación y eso fue lo que me
trajo aquí a monterrey a empezar verdad
mi carrera
entonces si lo tenía claro y fue
creciendo un poquito más
puede ser no claro que conforme vas
moldeando tu profesión te vas dando
cuenta que es lo que más te interesa
y vas dejando de lado lo que no te
interesa tanto para querer
especializarse en lo que te llama la
atención en los que disfrutas más hacer
y lo cuenta nos hace un poco cuando
vamos al cine
pues vamos bueno a mí lo personalmente
hace mucho la historia que tenga un
contenido pero bien es cierto que los
efectos visuales lo llevan a otra
dimensión ya veces quizás no lo
apreciamos del todo nos picamos un
poquito más en la narrativa y segovia
detrás de esto está aconteciendo
muchísimo muchísimas cosas no entonces
tú castilla en sí mismo los efectos
visuales es otra narrativa sí claro
lamentablemente con buenos digo la
mental porque ha habido muchos casos de
abuso de efectos visuales verdad para mí
desde mi punto de vista los mejores
efectos visuales y ustedes estarán de
acuerdo conmigo son los que le apoyan a
contar la historia no los que los que
son meramente apoyo para la narrativa
para alcanzar la visión de lo que el
director quiere contar
hay muchísimas películas que van de la
mano y son las favoritas una de ellas no
sé ustedes bien la oportunidad tuve una
oportunidad de ver ex machina
ella está privada muy de la mano con esa
visión y tenemos el otro extremo que es
el caso de que los efectos visuales pues
venden no venden venden boletos en
taquilla y ya y hay casos en los que se
abusa de esos sangrado tarde en que la
historia ya es secundaria y deja de ser
una historia contada con efectos
visuales para hacer efectos visuales
puros hay con una historia medio medio
bizarra que en realidad no no es
necesario ser contada con efecto ser el
ejemplo más más claro que tenemos es
transformers cosas que están muy bien
hechas
no me interpreten o sea yo voy a ver
tras otro ya sea lo que sea lo que baje
y dice voy a pasar que tengamos amigos
que apoyo solamente voy a las películas
con efectos porque me quedo dormido
me gusta mucho midnight in paris por
ejemplo me encantó narrativa además
quizás para otros aromas pero igual es
una historia que vale la pena una
película que vale la pena ver aunque no
sea
llena de efectos visuales
como te imaginas el futuro de los
efectos visuales está donde crees que
podría llegar se está aún por verse
falta tecnología por desarrollarse tanto
en el cine en el espacio físico que
vamos nosotros como como ves si nos
puede dar con una visión de eso si
termina
con esa pregunta que me hace se me viene
a la mente una conferencia que existían
en vancouver donde donde fue yola
thierry que es el que fue el supervisor
de efectos visuales de avatar fue a
presentarlos las letras de cámaras
efectos visuales de 'el hobbit' que en
ese entonces se acababa de estrenar
ilusión exactamente la misma pregunta
que tú estás haciendo y yo creo que se
lo voy a robar porque porque me gustó me
gusta mucho la forma en que respondió y
es que la todo depende de la visión que
tiene el director
si steven spielberg no haber venido con
la idea de que yo quiero crear
dinosaurios y que se vean reales y vamos
a usar las computadoras para apoyarnos
en las computadoras pero puede alcanzar
este efecto
más nadie se hubiera dado cuenta de que
oye las gráficas computacionales al
final en cuentas sirven para crear
efectos y que se vean reales y eso fue
lo que lo que impulsó la industria con
jurassic park este es la industria se
dio cuenta que ese es el camino a seguir
usando gráficas podemos realizar cosas
impensables
entonces regresando a tu pregunta todo
depende de hasta dónde quiere llegar
este
cada director y yo yo pienso que ya
estamos llegando fotorrealismo pero
vamos a llegar a un punto en que vamos a
dejar de ver
en una película con efectos visuales
cool para que no se engañe totalmente en
la realidad el ejemplo
más próximo que se me ocurra son las
nuevas películas de avatar que ahorita
mis colegas están frotándose las manos
para que porque en realidad vienen cosas
muy muy buenas para saber qué son los
efectos visuales van a ver
hiperrealistas
pues ojalá que nos toque ya no verlo
qué quiere decir cómo fue el
acercamiento a game of thrones o que
estuviste últimamente no como en cuenta
no es el momento si el contacto y la
expectativa te sorprendió ya estabas ahí
sí claro
con lo que mostramos un caso muy
especial porque mi compañero con
fundador de píxel rené allegretti que le
mando un saludo tuvo tuvo la experiencia
de trabajar con con la gente de rodeo
fex en montreal entonces de ahí mismo de
esos contactos que realizó durante su
trabajo en montreal nos pudieron
contactar para poder hacer trabajo de
actores vía remoto y nos fue
afortunadamente fue un impulso muy
grande para nuestra empresa porque
nosotros nos reconocieron como como
estos chavos si vienen en serio y si ve
y si vienen con todo para revolucionar
la industria aquí en un terreno
felicidades por eso yo gracias que que
te llevo es así
de aprendizaje y muchísimas cosas que te
sorprende más la forma en que trabaja en
la forma en que se trabaja mucho la
presión y que vayamos al puente celia
esto o no sé los todo el balón que ellos
te dan para hoy a partir de aquí puedes
dedicarte lo tuyo es lo que te
sorprendió más de bueno en general no
anda más de que mostraron sino de
trabajar en la industria es el grado de
nivel de calidad que necesitas que es
bastante alto y es un estatus que muchos
muchos artistas de aquí de monterrey
desconoce es que es prácticamente cada
pixel de la imagen tiene que estar
perfecta
y es algo muy difícil de conseguir
aunque a veces es hasta ridículo la
retroalimentación que usted puede andar
tienes que trabajar de esa forma porque
es cómo se trabaja en un estándar muy
muy alto y es el nuevo estándar que
nosotros queremos poner aquí tanto en
monterrey o como en méxico y aquí
conecto con otra pregunta hay un boom
del cine mexicano yo hablamos del cine
de la época de oro
y después ahora con los directivos que
tenemos pero bien es cierto como que
hace falta algo de producción es una
escuela de cine que pueden ser los
directivos y están teniendo éxito pero
con algunas casas detrás de los países
no sé cuándo cómo hacer una escuela
mexicana de producción estamos lejos de
ello para nada en méxico
nosotros siempre a donde quiera que
vamos mi compañero le decimos hay mucho
talento hay muchísimo de donde explotar
o sea de donde agarrar la cuestión es
llevarlos por el camino juntar un 'dream
team'
ya sea no nada más de artistas de
efectos visuales de directores
productores que vaya que nos estamos
conociendo que monterrey si hay mucha
gente que tiene mucho talento y queremos
todos tenemos un mismo objetivo el mismo
sueño que es éste alcanzar hacer
productos de mucha calidad aquí en
monterrey y está hablando de que se vea
con la misma estándar de calidad o
inclusivo está más que las instrucciones
de eeuu o de canadá esto es muy
alentador tú que estás viendo desde
desde dentro y si quisiéramos que esto
que se respiraron o que se viviera
tenemos aquí un horno que estaba
buscando expandir y creer ingresar y
creer y crecer en el dinero tú que qué
habilidades no necesitan para dedicarse
de eso de usar cuando vamos creciendo en
esto que igual tenemos una educación que
tomás estandarizada
no tuve en tu casa pues fuiste a
vancouver no a buscar
y que esos mínimos ingredientes que se
necesitan para amparar sí pues este no
es un arte muy abstracto es decir es a
final de cuentas somos artistas si tú
sabes lo subjetivo que puede llegar a
hacer es entonces lo que lo que yo
recomiendo es siempre tengan la
curiosidad de ir un poco más allá de lo
que los enseñe porque la escuela te
orienta de cierta forma te puede guiar
en el sentido de que es cuál es cuál es
o qué es lo que más te gusta para que
eso que es una especialidad pero al
final en cuentas eres tú y tú el que
decide nada más que tú el que decide si
vas echar ganas si te vas a desvelar
todos los días y vas a hacer
andersen en la escuela
y te vas a desvelar porque los que
porque aquí hay mucha competencia
también y la competencia que nosotros
tenemos es directamente bien
directamente desde vancouver y vaya que
sí es muy muy fuerte entonces para poder
este ponerte a la par necesitas hace
cuenta como si fueras a las olimpiadas
pues tiene que entrenar todos los días
entonces si si dijese entrenar un día
dos pues dejas de ya estás en desventaja
con respecto a tus competidores entonces
ha regresado tu pregunta yo creo que es
ir dar más de lo que de lo que te piden
en la escuela lo que tiene el trabajo no
se llegar a veces yo vengo cansado pero
es el caso al trabajo pero no no dejó de
ser llamadas de investigar que que puedo
seguir haciendo para para para traer más
contactos para traer más contratos y
para que nos caiga trabajo aquí aquí en
un terreno
y cuéntanos un poquito si subieron mucho
en el momento de lanzarse decir si nos
regresamos acá a monterrey y que ahora
ahora qué hago a quien tocó la puerta
ese proceso
qué tal si así fue fue un poco no fue
tanto lo que esperábamos la verdad a
donde quiera que vamos siempre nos hace
la misma pregunta de qué vengan ustedes
ya están ya trabajando en la industria
porque se realizaron los despiden lo que
pasó los corrieron y la verdad es que
para nada nosotros venimos aquí con el
objetivo de entrenar gente con las
técnicas de efectos visuales que no se
usan absolutamente no es una academia de
entrenamiento donde damos de montamos
taller talleres tipo workshops donde
entrenamos a la gente de efectos
visuales
y ese es nuestro sueño o sea formar la
industria y que eventualmente ya estamos
hablando de una serie de
o de un comercial sino de una película
entera y que la gente nos confía en
nosotros que podemos hacer este los
efectos visuales de una película de
y cuando mismo calibre que
en la industria internacional y han
hecho algún cortometraje de algo que sí
sí sí afortunadamente como te decía que
hay una comunidad muy grande de de
productores y directores y por lo mismo
este que estamos dando abriendo brecha
en esta industria
hemos tenido muchas muchas juntas donde
donde los director dicen de colegio sabe
que eso no se podía hacer que se podía
hacer aquí en monterrey y yo pensé que
efectos visuales era nada más
explosiones o oeste balazos que si son
efectos visuales no pero efectos
visuales es mucho más que eso no son
cosas que ustedes ni se pueden imaginar
existen muchos efectos visuales
invisibles de que piensan que el actor
va caminando por la calle en realidad no
está en la calle está en un set de
filmación con una pantalla abierta atrás
es muchísimo no a veces el cielo no es
ese cielo a veces estaba nublado lo
tuvieron que cambiar pusieron otros ojos
le cambiaron que la escena era en
invierno y la grande en otoño pues hay
que cambiar todo cosas cosas así que
suceden en set se tienen que arreglar en
posproducción y que son efectos visuales
que están tan bien hechos
no las notas y es nuestro trabajo que la
gente no note no se trabaja con artistas
visuales el trabajo está bien hecho
cuando cuando la noche
y en la ciudad tú te imaginas cómo
incorporar los efectos visuales en
nuestro día a día no sé si algunos
ejemplos de universidades están muy
alejados o como esta tecnología en meter
un poco más de efectos visuales no
solamente la industria cinematográfica
sino ir más allá nos
te refieres a aplicaciones así si
definitivamente los electores cuál es
donde más cubre la producción
audiovisual también puede también va de
la mano con la realidad virtual que
evita viene junto con la producción de
en 360 grados también imagínate como lo
que va a ser ver una película de terror
en 360 grados nos va a ser una
experiencia completamente diferente si
la gente se asusta de ir al cine mi
cliente que twitter que escucharon una
voz atrás dediquéis botes y que esté
un monstruo ahí no va a ser una
experiencia entonces si hay muchas
formas de incorporar los efectos
visuales al ala
a la tecnología como dices y también
estamos trabajando en ello último si
tienes algún retoque alguno a decir
bueno si pones adelantarnos algún
proyecto que éste es ahora mismo y que
sí
sí claro este práctico es y rápido
acabamos de terminar un videoclip de
música para una banda que está nominada
a los grammy y grammy latino se llama
ghetto kids la canción se llama coqueta
se gustan
buscarlo hasta el vídeo está en youtube
le está yendo muy bien hicimos
próximamente 35 tomas en la que
agregamos efectos visuales es algo que
nos había hecho antes aquí en monterrey
he estado muy orgulloso de eso están los
electores tan encantados y por supuesto
que vamos a seguir colaborando para
seguir para sacar cosas que se vean más
increíbles y seguirlo sorprendiendo los
a todos y ahorita está en puerta un
cortometraje también con mis mismos
colegas de vancouver están tan
emocionados con ese vídeo cuando les
mostré que quieren que quieren venir a
hacer un corto aquí en monterrey y de
terror te adelanto y de que iba a tener
muchos efectos visuales muy buenos nos
vamos a hacer si tiene pensado agregar
desarrollo de criaturas totalmente
computarizadas y se vas a ver muy cool y
tenemos estamos muy emocionados por eso
ya es un proyecto en puerta que el
próximo año que la jala sí sí sí se
realice pues te vamos a estar siguiendo
esto ojalá que estemos echarte porras
pues toda la comunidad te busque y ojalá
tengamos y se contagia más a más gente
pues muchísimas gracias pero no gracias
a ti
para cualquier información o si quiere
saber un poco más de nosotros
búsquenos en facebook somos pixel
perfecta y de zhuhai que publicamos todo
lo que trabajamos y todo lo que estamos
haciendo actualmente
si no se puede regalar un like para y
les deseamos bastante muchas gracias a
ti por la invitación y tengan un
excelente tarde
[Aplausos]